uh now our military analyst Sean Bell is
with his highly significant day isn't it
500 Days since the war started and now
these cluster bombs are being sent in
something that is highly controversial
why is that well it's worth pointing out
Nick that these cluster Munitions whilst
they're controversial today they were a
central part of most western Nations
inventory for many decades during the
Cold War
um they're an area weapon we before we
had Precision weapons we still needed to
strike targets like tanks which are
mobile very difficult to do with a
Precision strike whereas cluster
missions like this I used to fly some of
these when I was operating in Germany
they're incredibly effective against
tanks and the like and the way they
operate clearly is they are a single
munition delivered from an aircraft or
actually from um from the ground once
the weapon gets near the ground it
depends on how high you need it to
operate it will trigger the outer skins
to come off their weapon as we're about
to see here and then you can see that
the cluster Munitions then it releases a
whole load of Munitions which are then
forward in an area often the size of a
football pitch onto the ground now when
they hit the target and if the target's
anywhere in that football pitch that
will be hit the trouble is the vast
majority of those bomblets do not hit
the target they're expected to go off on
the ground but certainly back in the day
they had done rates of up to 10 percent
and those Munitions unexploded Munitions
would then lie around the battlefield
for years decades to come and there are
tens of thousands of Civilian casualties
that result in the decades since they
were used there has been a statistic
that says over 98 cents of the
casualties caused by these Munitions are
actually to civilians in the decades
afterwards as a result over 120 Nations
have banned their use anymore no longer
procure them no longer use them but of
course those Nations don't include
Russia Ukraine or America
um interesting timing here isn't it
we've got the NATO Summit uh coming up
and President Biden gave the green
lights to sending in these cluster
musician Munitions just yesterday
the timing is really important isn't it
because with the NATO billionaire Summit
next week I don't suppose that they
would really have wanted to announce
this just before it almost certainly
that reflects the timely imperative of
getting these weapons in uh to Ukraine
swiftly the US have been very careful to
brief this that they've said that the um
president zlinski desperate needs more
weapons that the counter offenses is is
strategically crucial over a month in
it's still not actually delivering the
results that they might have hoped for
and one of those reasons is the trenches
trench systems there and the minefields
trench systems shown here are incredibly
difficult for ukrainians to overcome you
could try and use Precision weapons to
take them out but you need so many
they're just not available whereas
cluster Munitions could be extremely
effective against these sorts of targets
they're certainly available and they're
available in significant numbers and
it's also worth pointing out despite the
nuanced argument around this President
zlinski is involved in a war of national
survival and therefore that's
undoubtedly influencing the decision of
the US and Ukraine I don't know less
allegations a bound to surface of
hypocrisy against the US and potentially
president zelenski that is absolutely
right and it's slightly difficult for
the US here because they've been very
critical in a part of the war of Russia
using um these these weapons um and yet
the Americans are not signatories to the
agreement they've got huge stockpiles
back in the U.S and actually Ukraine has
also used these weapons earlier in the
war as well what the U.S has said though
are two main things one of which is
Russia has used them on Ukraine soil so
it's Ukraine that has to deal with a
Fallout from all this not Russia and
secondly Russia's been targeting
civilian casualties this bit of video
footage is from kharkiv last year very
early in the war when Russia was
targeting the civilian population with
them and also therefore unexploded bombs
will lie in the middle of the city which
would be really dangerous Ukraine's been
clear we're not using these against our
own people we're not using them in the
cities they'll be in open areas they'll
be targeting the trenches and almost
certainly the minefields and if they are
effective then of course that will
justify uh the decision that the US and
Ukraine are making but whatever this
decision is incred incredibly
provocative very controversial and
whatever happens president silinski
alone will hold responsibility for the
unexploded audience and the impact that
will have for the next generation of his
Ukrainian colleagues yeah certainly
leave a legacy weren't they sure and
thank you for now